bleiben wir noch mal bei Robert Habeck
wissen die eigentlich was der Bundeswehr
Wirtschaftsminister und die Gebrüder
Grimm gemeinsam haben ich verrate Ihnen
jetzt es sind grandiose gute
Geschichtenerzähler alle weiter ja mit
der Wahrheit haben die Märchen von
Schneewittchen Rapunzel und Rotkäppchen
allerdings rein gar nichts zu tun
genauso wie die Märchen von Robert
Habeck und sein Team wenn es um den
Weiterbetrieb unserer Atomkraftwerke
geht
stellen Sie sich vor bei jeder Lüge der
Grünen würde die Nase vom
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
ein Stückchen wachsen Fans von Pinocchio
hätten ihre wahre Freude denn Gründe für
das märchenhafte nasenwachstum gibt es
viele und es werden immer mehr
das ein weiter Betrieb der letzten drei
deutschen Atommeiler beim Erreichen der
Klimaziele helfen würde passt Habeck so
gar nicht in den Plan wie die Welt am
Sonntag berichtete hat ausgerechnet sein
Ministerium errechnet dass die
Laufzeitverlängerung pro Jahr ab 2024
etwa 25 bis 30 Millionen Tonnen
CO2-Reduktion im deutschen Strommarkt
bewirken eine Information die aus den
Entwürfen des prüfvermerks ersatzlos
gestrichen wurden und was die Welt am
Sonntag Kollegen da herausgefunden haben
das wiegt natürlich wirklich schwer man
kann fast den Andruck haben der Minister
für Klimaschutz ist fast ein Minister
für Klimaschutz also Robert Habeck
verschweigt essentielle Dinge die seine
Beamten ihm und auch die Beamten von
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke
aufgeschrieben haben das habe ich mit
allen Mitteln versucht grüne Ideologien
umzusetzen zeigt auch der
pinocchio-moment
[Musik]
laut den Grünen sei angeblich die
Mehrzahl der Bürger für das AKW aus doch
da haben Harbeck und seine Partei wohl
vergessen die Menschen außerhalb ihrer
Ministerien zu befragen zum Glück gibt
es dafür
Meinungsforschungsinstitute wie Insa
eine repräsentative Umfrage ergab dass
64% der Bundesbürger für die längere
Laufzeit der AKW sind selbst 40% der
Grünwähler sehen das so
angeblich könnten Brennstäbe für den
Weiterbetrieb der AKW nicht rechtzeitig
geliefert werden so Robert Habeck fakt
ist die Meiler könnten im
streckenbetrieb funktionieren heißt die
Brennstäbe werden über ihr vorgesehenes
Ablaufdatum hinaus benutzt TÜV Fazit
möglich und die Nase wächst weiter
[Musik]
zum Schluss ein Totschlagargument geht
nicht das dachte sich Robert Habeck als
er zu verstehen gab die
Sicherheitschecks zum Weiterbetrieb der
AKW dauern viel zu lange auch in diesem
Punkt lag der Bundes Pinocchio falsch
denn die Meiler werden regelmäßig
geprüft ein TÜV Gutachten aus dem März
dieses Jahres ergab die Kraftwerke
könnten sicher und mit wenigen
zusätzlichen Maßnahmen weiter betrieben
werden
inzwischen wäre die lügen-nase des
Robert Habeck schon so lang dass sie
sogar aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium herausragt
also für jeden sichtbar zum Glück für
Robert Habeck war das mit der Nase alles
nur ein Märchen aber Achtung lügen haben
kurze Beine
ja wir sind jetzt mit Martin Huber
verbunden dem Generalsekretär der CSU
schon guten Morgen Herr Huber also wenn
man sich das alles mal so auf der Zunge
zergehen lässt die AKW löge die
Vertuschungen kann habeg eigentlich noch
im Amt bleiben
ja ich bin entsetzt Deutschland ist in
der größten Krise seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister belügt
monatelang das ganze Land und mich würde
auch interessieren was hat Olaf Scholz
gewusst der hat Olaf Scholz gewusst dass
Robert habeig das Land belügt oder wurde
Olaf stolz selbst belogen deswegen
musste ich auch Olaf Scholz erklären
oder die Konsequenzen sind je nachdem
was der Fall war also sie fordern ganz
klar mehr Transparenz was sollte ihrer
Ansicht nach Robert habe vergessen
ich denke Robert Habeck ist denn nicht
länger tragbar wie gesagt Deutschland
ist in der größten Krise seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg wir haben große
Probleme in der Energiesicherheit es
gibt viele Menschen die sich
berechtigterweise Sorgen machen es gibt
viele Betriebe die sich Sorgen machen
wie sie über den Winter kommen in
Mittelstand in Handwerk die Bäckereien
die Metzgereien und Robert Habeck steht
hier praktisch ohne mit der Wimper zu
zucken grüne Ideologie über das Wohl des
Landes er ist der zuständige
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ihm ist das
grüne Seelen halt wichtiger als die
Versorgungssicherheit des Landes ich
halte das für untragbar was würden Sie
denn von einem Wirtschaftsminister jetzt
in dieser Situation konkret erwarten
ich würde mir erwarten dass er im Sinne
des Landes jetzt wirklich schaut dass
die Laufzeitverlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke angepackt wird und nicht
nur ein Placebo-Effekt für ein paar
wenige Wochen und ich würde mir auch
vorstellen dass er die Lieferverträge
unterschreibt die Frage ist ja immer
noch warum hat Italien einen
Liefervertrag mit Katar und Deutschland
nicht oder Scholz war ja auch mit ihm
unterwegs in Saudi Arabien in Norwegen
in Kanada es wurden keine Verträge
abgeschlossen und Robert habe geht es ja
offensichtlich nicht um den Klimaschutz
wenn ich mir dann anschaue dass drei
schwimmende ölkraftwerke eingesetzt
werden und eben nicht die Laufzeit der
Kernkraftwerke entsprechend dauerhaft
verlängert wird ich brauche doch auch
keine Studie um festzustellen dass eine
Verlängerung der Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke einen Preis dämpfenden
Effekt hat das weiß doch jedes Kind
jeder der sich mit Wirtschaft
beschäftigt weiß wenn das Angebot
verknappt wird und die Nachfrage gleich
bleibt oder steigt dann wird auch der
Preis steigen ich bin wirklich
fassungslos dass man für diese bisschen
Weisheit im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
offensichtlich Kommissionen und Studien
einsetzen muss das weiß doch wie gesagt
jedes Kind Robert Habeck hat das immer
wieder ausgeblendet er ist wirklich ein
Sicherheitsrisiko für die
Energiesicherheit in Deutschland
wie gut glauben sie sind all die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die jetzt mit
ganz viel Angst in den Winter schauen
denn derzeit überhaupt noch mit der
Ampel als Regierung aufgehoben
ich glaube dass sie überhaupt nicht gut
aufgehoben sind und das zeigen ja auch
sämtliche Erhebungen wie groß die Sorgen
sind die Menschen sind in großer Sorge
und durch die Lügen von Robert Habeck
werden die Sorgen ja auch
nachvollziehbarer Weise größer und ich
kenne auch viele die sich bei mir melden
zum Beispiel auch Betriebe aus
energieintensiven Branchen die mir sagen
sie wissen gar nicht was sie ab 1 Januar
bezahlen für den Strom weil sie gar
keinen Stromvertrag mehr bekommen das
heißt die Märkte nehmen diese Knappheit
ja schon vorweg die diese Betriebe
können ja auch gar nicht mehr
kalkulieren und das wird auch
Folgewirkungen haben in der
Wertschöpfung und deswegen wenn es schon
immer heißt jede Kilowattstunde zählt
dann müsste auch jedes Kilowatt genutzt
werden stattdessen geht es den Grünen um
ihr eigenes Seele Heil die Grünen sind
im Kern eine Hardliner Partei gegen die
Kernkraftwerke sie sind die Partei und
die sind nicht in der Lage
Regierungsverantwortung zu übernehmen
das zeigt sich in dieser Stunde wieder
ganz deutlich
jetzt hat die Expertenkommission
tatsächlich endlich mal einen Vorschlag
auf dem Tisch gelegt zur gaspreisbremse
was halten Sie von diesem Vorschlag
die Expertenkommission hat ja mit dem
Vorliegen des Vorschlags auch deutlich
gemacht dass wertvolle Zeit verspielt
wurde und erst heute war ja auch wieder
zu lesen dass die Ampel zwar Termine in
den Raum stellt diese Termine aber in
keinster Weise einzuhalten sind und das
ist ja auch das was wir kritisieren
kritisieren müssen dass monatelang die
Ampel nur zögert und zaudert und wenn
sie entscheidet im entscheidet sie zu
spät und zu lasch es ist doch absurd
dass eine gaspreisbremse erst ab dem
ersten März wirken soll wenn die
Heizperiode praktisch vorbei ist und ich
möchte schon darauf hinweisen dass wir
als CSU bereits im Juli den Vorschlag
unterbreitet haben eine gaspreisbremse
zu entwickeln hätte man das im Juli
gemacht dann könnte sie jetzt greifen
jetzt ist die Ampel wieder mal zu spät
dran sagt CSU-Generalsekretär Martin
Huber vielen herzlichen Dank Ihnen für
dieses Gespräch
[Musik]